Quiz time or the following words?
Chinese or Japanese first?
Yes,
it's Japanese next.
It's Chinese.
Next.
Actually this is both Chinese and
Japanese and finally,
actually this is neither.
This is ty.
What you thought.
All Asian languages are the same.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the question how
similar our Chinese and Japanese,
a lot of people look at a map of Asia
and see how close to Japan and China are
or they might look at a sample of
Chinese and Japanese writing and think
that something looks similar and they
might conclude that the two languages
are similar,
but are they really similar?
Well,
the short answer is no.
They are completely different languages,
but Japanese has been highly influenced
by Chinese and it's vocabulary and then
it's writing systems.
Chinese and Japanese do not share any
common origin and they don't belong to
the same language.
Family,
the Chinese languages belonged to the
CNO,
to Betson language.
Family in Japanese as far as we know
belongs to the Japonica language.
Family phonology.
First off,
the phonology of the language is,
is very different with the most basic
difference being that Chinese is a tonal
language.
While Japanese is not a tonal language
is one in which there are tones or
pitches that helped determine the
meaning of the words you use if you use
the wrong tone than the meaning of the
word changes.
Here's an example,
the word for teacher sure.
And the word for naive slow.
Sure.
And the word for old fashion.
So I'm sure that Chinese teachers get
called naive and old fashion all the
time by mistake or maybe not by mistake.
In Japanese,
there are basically no tones like this
that determine the meaning of words.
In Japanese,
there is something called pitch accent,
which means that the syllables of a word
have either a higher pitch or a lower
pitch,
but they're not like the tones and
Chinese because they typically don't
determine the meaning of the word.
They're more like stress.
In English structure,
the structure and grammar of the two
languages is completely different.
At the most basic level,
Chinese is an Svo language,
while Japanese is an Sov language.
Here's an example in Chinese.
Sure.
This means he speaks Chinese and you can
see s the o subject verb object and
here's that sentence translated into
Japanese,
how they walk to go google on Nasim us
here we can see s o v subject,
object,
verb and you can see there are some
extra little words in Japanese that
don't exist in the Chinese sentence.
For example,
Japanese has the topic marker Wa which
doesn't exist in Chinese and Japanese
also has the object marker all which
doesn't exist in Chinese.
Chinese is an analytic language,
which basically means that you create a
sentence by a placing independent
elements side by side.
Analytic languages like Chinese do not
use inflection.
Inflection means modifying words to
indicate some kind of grammatical
meaning like plural,
gender,
tenths or case.
You don't change any part of a word in
order to change its meaning.
Instead,
you can add to the meaning of that word
by adding an extra word next to it.
Japanese,
on the other hand,
it's an a glutinous of language that
uses inflection.
A gluten native language is used a lot
of affixes.
Rather than just placing independent
worlds side by side,
you attach additional pieces to words to
add or modify.
Meaning this kind of inflection in
Japanese means that Japanese words are
often longer than Chinese words and that
it may take a few words in Chinese to
translate one Japanese word.
In these Chinese sentences,
we can see that there's no inflection or
this sentence means I go to school or
choose this sentence means I went to
school,
so no part of the verb is changed to
indicate the past tense.
We can show the past tense by just
adding a time expression.
Now these similar sentences in Japanese
show inflection.
The sentence means I go to school
[inaudible] I went to school.
Once I see what [inaudible] does and the
polite form of I go to school
[inaudible] I want to go to school.
What does she wear?
De Gaulle,
achy tie.
In this Japanese example,
we use inflection,
changing the word to the Eqi form,
and then we use a gluten nation to
attach a form that shows intention tied
in Chinese though there's no inflection
or agglutination,
you just add an extra word like this.
That's just a brief sample of how
different the grammar is in Japanese and
Chinese.
Basically they're completely different
languages when it comes to their
grammatical structure,
vocabulary and Chinese characters.
The one area in which there is some
similarity between Chinese and Japanese
is in vocabulary and in the use of
Chinese characters.
During a period of great Chinese
influence between the fifth and ninth
century Ce,
there was a huge amount of borrowing
from early middle Chinese into Japanese.
Japanese originally had no written form,
so Chinese began to be used as the
literary language and as the language of
science and religion,
Chinese vocabulary began to be borrowed
into Japanese and the Chinese writing
system was gradually adapted to fit the
Japanese language.
So not only were at vocabulary board,
but the Chinese characters that
represent them were also adopted.
60% of the vocabulary words used in
Japanese are of Chinese origin.
But that includes all of the words in
the dictionary.
And that includes a lot of very
specialized academic and formal
vocabulary that's mainly used in writing
and spoken Japanese.
The number of Chinese loan words used as
much lower at about 18% the borrowed
words were almost all Chinese nouns,
even though in Japanese they might be
used as verbs or as adjectives.
That's just one way in which the
vocabulary is used differently.
But also with the pronunciation of those
Chinese words that were borrowed into
Japanese changed to match the Japanese
phonological system.
And that included the loss of the tones
of those words.
And also these words were borrowed a
long time ago,
which means that the words have also
changed in pronunciation in Chinese.
So the pronunciation has diverged quite
a bit,
meaning that modern Japanese
pronunciation and modern Chinese
pronunciation of similar characters or
words is quite different.
And it's also important to point out
that mandarin was not the standard form
of Chinese back in those days when those
vocabulary words were borrowed into
Japanese.
So even at the time they were borrowed,
the pronunciation was different from
standard Chinese today.
And what I understand,
the modern Japanese pronunciation of
those lone words is often more similar
to modern cantonese than it is to
Mandarin.
These examples show how the same words
are pronounced very differently.
In Japanese ended Mandarin,
the word for family in Japanese,
it's cut date and actually in Japanese
the meaning is more like household or
home and in Mandarin Jab him.
Next,
the word for death in Japanese,
she bolt and amendment to the wall next
to word four season in Japanese key set
to and in Mandarin Gpa and the word for
home country in Japanese vocal group and
in Mandarin or so you can see that these
words look the same and they have
basically the same meaning,
but they sound very different.
So Chinese vocabulary represented by
Chinese characters were borrowed into
Japanese,
but those Chinese characters were also
them applied to native Japanese
vocabulary that had a related meaning
for those Chinese loan words.
That means that a Chinese speaker can
often look at a native Japanese word and
understand its core meaning without
knowing that Japanese words,
because the Chinese character is used to
represent it.
So Chinese people can often read a text
in Japanese and they can make sense of
the basic meaning of it based on the
Chinese characters,
but they won't understand all the
details.
And the same is true in reverse.
Japanese people can look at a Chinese
texts and kind of make sense of the
meaning of it based on the Chinese
characters that they know.
But it is easy to misunderstand the
details of what's written,
especially if they have zero knowledge
of the other language.
Here are some Japanese example sentences
that have the same Chinese characters,
but the meaning is very different
because of the inflection that's used.
Nicole [inaudible],
that means the cat eats fish,
Nicola suck and [inaudible].
That means the cat doesn't eat fish.
Nicola suck.
Another topic.
That means the cat ate fish in the past
tense.
Nicola [inaudible] Samadhi,
the cap plans to eat fish.
Nicola [inaudible] data.
That means the cat was eaten by a fish.
So a Chinese speaker of reading these
sentences would get the core meaning of
the Chinese characters,
but they would miss some meaning in the
inflection.
For example,
the negative or the past tense or
intention or the passive form.
Especially.
The last example could be highly
misunderstood,
so imagine you're an English speaker
reading something with English long
words.
It might look something like this,
Catholic glofish,
blah,
blah.
Of course,
even after just a little bit of study in
Japanese or Chinese speaker could
probably learn enough to understand
basic Japanese sentences like that.
For me,
as someone who's studied Japanese two,
a relatively advanced level,
the same as true in reverse.
When I was in Taiwan last year on the
subway for example,
I could read a lot of the advertisements
and I would get most of the meaning.
I wouldn't understand all of the Chinese
characters,
but I would get usually three out of
four of them and the fourth one would be
new to me because in Chinese there are a
lot of characters that actually aren't
used in Japanese at all,
but just getting three out of four of
them was often enough to understand the
basic meaning of that advertisement.
But of course I had no idea how to
pronounce those Chinese characters and
if I tried to read them out loud like
the Japanese,
I would hear laughter from both my
girlfriend and from local bystanders.
It might seem strange that I can look at
a Chinese character in Chinese and
understand what it means without knowing
how to say it,
but think of it as a symbol,
like a number.
The number seven right here is
pronounced differently in different
languages,
but when you see it,
you know what it means,
no matter how you pronounce it.
Chinese characters are kind of like that
except that they represent a much wider
range of meanings.
The Chinese characters used in any
particular sentence can be very
different from those used in the other
language for a sentence of similar
meaning and in Japanese there are a lot
of compound words that were created from
Chinese characters,
but those compound words don't actually
exist in Chinese.
These are called Wasa Congo,
which means something like Chinese
vocabulary created in Japan.
Here are some examples of Wasa icon
will,
some were created to represent things
unique to Japan,
like Ninja Geisha and others were
created during the Meiji period to
represent western concepts like
democracy,
men shoes.
So even though you might recognize a lot
of characters when you look at some
texts in the other language,
they might be used in a very different
ways.
So the meaning will be unclear.
A Chinese speaker might be confused by
Wasi Kango when they tried to read some
Japanese and Japanese people might be
confused when they read Chinese because
there are a lot of Chinese characters
that were never boiled into Japanese in
the first place or they're not used in
modern Japanese.
But in either case,
even basic knowledge of the other
language would help in reading
comprehension quite a bit.
Japanese returned moen words in Chinese,
so as we've discussed already,
lots of Chinese vocabulary was borrowed
into Japanese,
but some Japanese vocabulary has also
been borrowed into Chinese.
A moment ago I mentioned Wasa Kango,
Japanese vocabulary created from Chinese
roots vocabulary that didn't exist in
Chinese,
but some of those Lasa Kango have
actually been borrowed from Japanese
into Chinese.
Some sources say that such vocabulary
accounts for around 30% of modern
Chinese vocabulary.
Of course,
the way those returned loan words are
pronounced as based on the modern
Chinese pronunciation of the Chinese
characters.
Here are some examples.
The word for history in Japanese that
Kishi in Mandarin,
the shoe,
the word for industry in Japanese Kogel
in mandarins,
the word for electron or electronic in
Japanese.
Then cheat in Mandarin and the word for
injection in Japanese to shop in
Mandarin jewel.
Sure.
The word for philosophy in Japanese.
Tetsu got goats in Mandarin.
Yeah,
the workforce system in Japanese,
Cato and in Mandarin.
She told him,
and most Chinese people these days are
probably not even aware that those words
were borrowed from Japanese.
It's also important to point out that in
mainland China,
simplified Chinese characters are now
used as opposed to the traditional
Chinese characters used in Taiwan and
Hong Kong.
That means that someone from mainland
China may have some more trouble
recognizing Japanese Kanji than someone
from Taiwan.
For example,
someone short,
Chinese and Japanese are very different
languages,
especially the spoken languages.
Even though there was a lot of
vocabulary borrowed from Chinese in the
Japanese and the little bit from
Japanese into Chinese,
only in writing are those two languages
somewhat intelligible because of the
Chinese characters that are used.
So the question of the day for Japanese
speakers,
what's your experience when you look at
Chinese texts,
are you able to understand the basic
meanings based on the Chinese characters
and similarly for Chinese speakers?
What happens when you look at a Japanese
texts?
Can you understand the basic meaning or
do you get confused because of the
different way that the Chinese
characters are used?
Thanks again to all my patrion
supporters and I want to say thanks to
all the new subscribers who joined this
month.
There are a lot of you and you are very
welcome and very appreciated.
Thank you for watching.
Have a nice.